disons que comme je devais a du sens je
crois pas donner du sperme 1973 pour la
première fois les français peuvent
donner leur sperme c'est la solution
pour les couples dont l'homme a des
problèmes de fertilité
même si c'est un sujet tabou à l'époque
les donneurs témoigne à visage caché le
début on sait pas on sait pas comment on
recommence à se faire évidemment c'est
ce qui intrigue beaucoup on s'imagine
qu'il va y avoir une machine chose comme
ça finalement c'est tout à fait naturel
des conditions pour donner son sperme
sont strictes
il faut avoir moins de 45 ans être en
bonne santé et surtout à l'époque des
critères moraux être marié avoir déjà un
enfant en bonne santé et obtenir
l'accord de l'épouser
quand on a des enfants on comprend le
problème des personnes qu'ils peuvent
pas en avoir justement ce que vous en
avez
nous avons trois enfants le nombre de
donneurs ne suffit pas face à la demande
importante comme le regrette le
professeur grignon en 1976 le résultat
actuellement et que grand nombre de
couples continuent à vivre dans cette
angoisse de cet enfant qui ne vient pas
compte sur nous et nous sommes obligés
de demander des délais qui sont de plus
en plus important et qui aggravent
certainement avec impatience bien sûr et
7 ans voisin
d'autant que le nombre de dons par homme
est limitée nous nous bornons à trois
enfants à partir d'un même donneur ceci
pour limiter vous l'imaginez bien les
risques de consanguinité
s'il se produit une anomalie il est
évident que nous estimons que nous avons
une responsabilité
le don de sperme est gratuit mais
suscite des convoitises
un trafic s'organisent des médecins
rémunère les donneurs pour les motiver
comme le révèle cet appel téléphonique
en 1983 nos camarades qui m'a donné
votre votre nom m'a dit que
nous étions des dommages et qu'elle est
là je me donnais le chiffre pour me
donner au monde et 500 francs
cc c'est moins 300 francs aujourd'hui
encore les dons manque l agence de la
biomédecine multiplient les campagnes
d'appels l'ouverture de la pma pour les
couples de femmes et la potentielle
levée de l'anonymat des donneurs font
craindre une baisse des dons à l'avenir
[Musique]